hey guys my name is Jess it is the
second of august and here's all the
things that mattered in gaming for you
Tuesday if you love overwatch and you're
excited for your limbic then you're in
good company as it seems the blizzard
are also getting in the sporting spirit
Blizzard have injected a new Olympics
themes update into overwatch that
includes a new three-on-three brawl mode
called aletheia ball in plain terms it's
like rocket League in overwatch your
teams of Lucio's will try to knock a
massive ball into the opposing team's
goal using either his punch or Soundwave
ability and personal speed boost your
ultimate is also swapped out for one
that caused the ball over to your
direction and certain map areas lets you
jump higher on top of the new mode a
bunch of characters are getting
olympic-themed skins that you can
collect by opening new limited-edition
Summer Games Luke boxes also included
are new icons and spray the standard
lewd boxes have been temporarily removed
from the store Blizzard has said this is
just the start of their foray into
seasonal content / watch Game Informer
have dug seriously deep into Destiny's
new rise of iron expansion and here are
the highlights one new addition is the
large social space though when to peak
which will include new vendors offering
up here and bounties though winter peak
can be found next to the plague lands
which are filled with nasty devil
splices mutated forms of the Fallen the
expansion features a new story about the
iron Lords and Lord Saladin which takes
place over five missions much like the
last expansion the taken King you'll
have a bunch more missions today gone
after your finish the main campaign rise
of iron also adds in the cooperative
aruna called Arkham storage which you'll
need specific items to trigger as you'd
expect taking out your clothes in here
will grant you exclusive
yep speaking of the new expansion
features new relics and artifacts that
give you special abilities like
deflecting energy-based projectiles with
swords the new light cap is 385 and the
light level of gear has been scaled to
match after the release of rise of ions
raid a few weeks after launch the level
cap will be boosted again to 400 rise of
iron will also bring along more cosmetic
ornament items Bungie told Game Informer
it was important for them to answer fan
questions about the background and story
that was the focus in the new expansion
finally the xbox one s is now available
and we're getting a good idea of what
extra performance it could be offering
the new model is certainly smaller but
Microsoft have spoken to digital foundry
about whether it actually offers
performance improvements senior director
of product marketing and planning Albert
Penello explained the key is that we did
not want customers to expect any change
in game performance for existing titles
while the GPU has been bumped up to a
914 megahertz clock speed Piniella said
this was to allow developers to offer
HDR content without incurring informants
hit that said because of the increased
GPU performance Microsoft who said some
games may seem minor performance
improvements digital foundry noted that
the frame rate of project cuts hit man
and batman arkham knight appear to
perform quite a bit better thanks to the
GPU boost you can check out the full
report and our review of the xbox one
Esk on gamespot educators like the
stories on flat floor and Rainbow six
siege and I will see you again tomorrow